buonasera allora cominciamo anche io mi
porto dietro nel tempo
ginevra una sera d'estate anzi di giugno
perché quella del 1816 l'anno che fu
ricordato come l'anno senza estate
qualche mese prima c'era stata la più
grande eruzione vulcanica di tutti i
tanti in indonesia per cui il cielo si
oscurò le temperature si abbassarono e
per mesi e mesi e l'europa fu scritta da
piogge torrenziali e incessante quindi
ritorniamo a villa diodati dopo un
gruppo di amici che pensava di passare
una vacanza sul lago in realtà si annoia
a lume di candela i fulmini brillano
sull'acqua dell'agri ginevra
a un certo punto con modelli del gruppo
degli amici lord byron si alza e lancia
una sfida perché non scriviamo una
storia di orrore di procura di fantasmi
e poi sceglieremo il vincitore
a quell'epoca mary shelley aveva 18 anni
e solo due anni dopo
dopo appunto grazie a questa sfida nasce
funk stein che quindi quest'anno fa 200
anni quindi la più grande storia gotica
di orrore e scritto comunque da una
teenager e la cosa interessante perché
ne parliamo oggi perché comunque
frankestein che comunque il medico e non
il mostro si dalla natura con la sua con
la sua attività comunque cerca di
attività comunque cupa pericolosa solo
nostro di sfuggire di mano con effetti
drammatici
eppure in quella storia si santa tutta
la trazione di mari per le lusinghe
della scienza addirittura franca e stana
fu considerato una storia talmente
maschile pubblicato inizialmente come
anonima è comunque una risalita anche la
figlia di una famosa femminista
dell'epoca ben lontana dall attivismo
delle suffragette si parla del 1792 che
aveva scritto appunto un articolo molto
famoso sui diritti delle donne
quindi in qualche modo il la scienza con
appunto anche con i suoi pericoli quando
appunto il mistero del del rapporto fra
scienza e vita fra uomo e tecnologia
il la situazione della scoperta prevale
il quello che ci tengo a dire è appunto
il maresciallo in qualche modo già
identifica allora lo scienziato come
qualcuno dotato di superpoteri capace di
fare cose come comandare i fulmini
riprodurre terremoti che non è a tutti
di fare io personalmente devo dire sono
stata come sono arrivata la scienza sono
stata un'adolescente molto tormentata ad
un'aula filosofia durava la letteratura
però nel momento di decidere che cosa
avrei fatto nella mia vita temevo di
mettermi una in una dimensione troppo
chiusa su se stessa e avevo invece
voglia di prendere il mio baricentro e
buttaro lontano il più lontano possibile
da tutti quei turbamenti e invece
sentivo e ho scelto quindi di fare
fisica e una speranza che mi ha
trasformato dopo non sono stata più la
stessa
perché mi ha obbligato per poter capire
il tempo per poter capire dei fenomeni
concime obbligato uscire a fare quel
passo che ti porta fuori della tua zona
di conforto che poi alla nostra zona
dell'esperienza quella che in qualche
modo definisce le traiettorie secondo
cui la nostra immaginazione viene
incanalata e secondo cui noi decidiamo
cosa è possibile da cosa invece non lo è
ora il termine desiderio viene da
desidera s essere lontani dalle stelle
abbiamo dentro di noi tutti una tensione
una merito a raggiungere una cosa di più
grandi di noi in realtà cambio dicevano
vuol dire che siamo soli
io invece dico no vuol dire che abbiamo
dentro di noi qualcosa che ci porta
sempre ad andare oltre quello che siamo
e ed è questo appunto questa apertura
della mente questo dover entrare in zone
pericolose per riuscire
ad arrivare là dove non si è ancora
arrivati è una speranza che la scienza
ci ci offre soffre tutti sono stati io
parlo della fisica perché il mio campo e
quindi per esempio vi faccio un esempio
c'è una sostanza in fisica si chiama lei
un superfluido tutto fondamentale per
raggiungere le temperature molto basse
questa sostanza al di sotto di una certa
temperatura perde la terza dimensione
cosa vuol dire che sta mettete in un
bicchiere si possono anche vedere su
youtube c'è un bellissimo video della
bbc
se la mettete in un bicchiere abbassate
la temperatura a un certo punto il
liquido si comincerà ad arrampicare se
vuol dire il bicchiere e si spiaccica
era sul tavolo quella sostanza fenomeno
tantissimo bellissimo di einstein si
chiama è un fenomeno tantissimo per cui
praticamente le particelle cadono tutti
in uno stato lo stato zero e quindi e
diventa un film quello che era prima a
tre dimensioni non bicchiere diventò una
pellicola spiaccicata somma su un tavolo
un altro
un altro esempio di come vengano
stravolti come acquistano superpoteri e
attraverso il concetto del tempo io amo
molto questa frase di bart e che dice
praticamente non basta montare un
orologio per capire cos'è il tempo
allora il tempo l'emozione dei
superpoteri che ci dà che ci dà la
chance in realtà la viviamo sempre noi
guardare lontano nello spazio significa
guardare lontano nel tempo quando voi
osservate un cero stasera se non ci sono
onore tutti quelle quei puntini luminosi
sono istanti di tempo diversi la loro
distanza è un momento diverso l'uno
dell'altro
quindi il presente della persona accanto
a me con cui sto guardando questo cielo
non è il presente di quello che sto
osservando quello è un passato
stessa cosa quando prendo un monito su
un terrazzo vede il tramonto il nostro
sole a 150 milioni di chilometri da noi
la luce deve viaggiare fino a noi questa
moto già non c'è più da otto minuti
quando noi ancora lo stiamo osservando
romanticamente e vi faccio quindi vedere
questa foto questa è una foto
spettacolari presa dal telescopio di
hubble che un telescopio in orbita da
più di 20 anni e che ci ha dato delle
immagini spettacolari del nostro
universo ma questa è una delle più
significative perché guardando una zona
di cielo per 11 giorni e quindi
aspettando questa luce che arrivava dal
passato questa foto ha fotografato tra
le prime che l'asse mai esistite non
dico guardando quasi all'inizio
dell'universo ma ci sono tante baby ebbe
di galassie in questa fotografia e
vediamo anche al punto che l'asse
spinale galassi cannibali e le galassie
scusa telegrafi ellittica che sappiamo
essere in gran parte cannibale ce ne
sono mangiate altre ma questa è una foto
in cui stiamo guardando così indietro
nel tempo come non eravamo ancora mai
riusciti quindi un senso di potere un
senso di qualcosa che poteva sembrare
impossibile e invece assolutamente reale
ripeto anche l'esperienza di un cielo
stellato sui bordi di un buco nero il
tempo si ferma anche al centro della
nostra galassia esista un buco nero che
si chiama sanitario a circa 4 milioni di
sole per pesa circa 4mila ed i soli e
sul bordo di un buco nero proprio perché
la gravità è molto forte il tempo si
ferma perché perché parlo di la vita
perché una delle grandi scoperte di
einstein è ancora lì la scoperta di
riuscire ad andare oltre tutto ciò che
si è mai conosciuto quindi ha
completamente sradicare il determinismo
della nostra speranza sarebbe
l'intuizione di capire che il tempo è
una dimensione così come lo spazio e
quindi lo spazio tempo e come se
avessimo un tappeto elastico se ci
mettiamo una palla quindi in questo caso
la nostra terra
questo tappeto sicura quindi se questo è
un pezzettino di questo di questo
tappetino nel momento in cui si
si curva perché c'era c'è la palla che
ci va sopra questo pezzettino che è un
minuto diventa così si allungano
lo vedete la rete si allunga quindi un
minuto vicino alla terra o sulla terra
passa più lentamente che un minuto sulla
stazione spaziale addirittura su un
aereo o minuto nello spazio quindi al
ted matera ciò abbiamo qualche picco
secondo in più cartelle cortina
quindi è comunque un vantaggio quindi
questo per dirvi che riuscire a a uscire
da quello che si sa è guardarsi con
occhi diversi e soprattutto riconoscere
che siamo un nulla un puntino cominciò a
leibniz perché c'è qualcosa invece che
niente niente sarebbe stato più semplice
eppure siamo qui in questo universo
appunto muto non c'è suono nell'universo
universo indifferente e noi qui con i
nostri super poteri di riuscire a farci
delle domande a porgere e anche a
cercare delle risposte allora il
silenzio infinito ed eterno istat
riferiti di sgomenti ha ricevuto a scale
questa è una foto presa da una
fotocamera quindi presa da cassini della
terra vista da saturno allora perché
nasciamo tutti i piccoli esploratori
conosciamo le domande dei bambini non
hanno paura di niente per cacciare blu
perché perché la luce perché sulla luna
c'è la luce quando non c'è a casa
eccetera eppure che l'abbiano perdiamo
questa insolenza cominciamo ad avere
paura di fare domande sbagliate
il muro della matematica piano piano si
alza e e lentamente la scienza diventa
qualcosa per pochi e questo è veramente
un peccato perché io penso che così come
una vita senza arte letteratura è una
vita comunque poveri stanza con la vita
senza chance a stans ma si perde una
straordinaria opportunità e la questione
è se se l'avventura della scienza e così
incredibile perché sono così poche le
ragazze che scelgono di studiare scienza
e questo è effettivamente un problema un
programma addirittura oggi nelle materie
strano
finisce alta tecnologia ingegneria e
matematica solo una ragazza su tre
appunto scegliere di prendere una laurea
in queste materie e addirittura c'è un
paradosso in cui in fisica ancora meno
in ingegneria ancora meno e nel mondo
del digitale che il mondo di domani
c'è veramente un numero bassissimo di
donne vi dico che nel 2016 in italia si
sono arrivate in informatica a 117 donne
su un totale di 140 mila laureati quindi
il mondo del digitale che il mondo che
ci apparterrà verrà scritto da uomini
con un buy out di algoritmi di cui non
so se mai ci renderemo conto ciò che è
un paradosso che invece nei paesi
quindi noi abbiamo un articolo uscito
quest'estate nei paesi che hanno la più
alta gender equality quindi i paesi
nordici con i loro sistemi educativi
completamente moderni eccetera c'è il
numero più basso di ragazzi che studiano
latere scientifica nei paesi emergenti
dove invece non ci non c'è già delle
coliche c'è un sistema appunto
legislativo che non protegge la donna
parlo dell'algeria della tunisia della
dell'albania c'è il più alto numero di
ragazze che stanno studi scientifici e
come è una cosa strana da capire io ho
la mia ho la mia e le mie
interpretazioni ma mi spaventa pensare
che in svezia se non è l'incentivo di
trovare un posto di lavoro perché
comunque lo trovi anche se fa il poeta
veramente per fare il poeta e non vuoi
fare lo scienziato allora questo è
questo sono le donne che hanno studiato
cia che hanno vinto nove le chance ha
quindi all'inizio del nome vedete quanto
sono poche in ogni caso la carriera
delle donne scientifica è un problema in
modo scientifico un problema considerate
che neppure chiuso quindi nei bordi che
analizzano i paper nella pubblicazione
c'è solo il 20 per cento di donne
se poi questi preview sono pagati il
numero scende al 15 per cento e oggi
solo il 17 per cento degli scienziati
che guadagno più di 100 mila dollari
l'anno sono donne quindi c'è un
programma il work in progress
io se devo dare una cifra anche se non è
scienza il west quindi il word e coloni
foro dice ci vorranno 217 anni per
colmare il divario di genere sul mercato
del lavoro quindi altro che work in
progress il uno dei problemi che sembra
influenzare l'ingresso delle donne sono
gli steroli questa una campagna fatta
l'italia da tale spazio e cioè il c'è
uno studio ocse pisa quindi che valuta i
ragazzi a 15 anni attraverso tutti i
paesi ocse che dimostra che non solo due
fattori su cui si decide se si vuole
fare chance o così si vuole fare altro
in una divaricazione concia quell'esame
a parità di competenza i genitori hanno
tre volte che aspettativa essere maschio
alfa ingegneria che creda ragazza che
cosa faccia magari medicina biologia o
altro considerate che sicuramente
diciamo questa differenza di presenza
che da recenti c'era una legata a
capacità naturali ci sono mille e studi
tra cui uno di nathan che uscito fuori
recentemente che dimostra che non c'è
nessuna nessuna differenza il problema è
che appunto c'è una pressione una
pressione che viene che viene dalle
famiglie che viene dall ambiente e che
porta e che determinate nelle scelta il
mallo sterotipo quindi lo sterotipo
kahuna che comincia ad essere una cosa
molto importante tanto è vero che cosa
gli stereotipi
questo è lo stereotipo del ragazzo di
silicon valley 9 reti ed occhio nudo non
tutti i maschi
in realtà nel 1967 questo articolo tv
del cosmopolitan e vediamo che la
computer ghersi
reale era invece intervista che ne so
perché era appunto una famosa
informatica dell'epoca che spiegava che
le donne sono naturalmente portate per
informate un po come preparare la cena
devi scegliere gli ingredienti devi
metterli insieme
e alla fine avrai un piatto superbo
quindi c'era allora molte donne che
facevano informatica addirittura negli
anni ottanta negli stati uniti si è
arrivati al 60 per cento al 40 per cento
e poi la cosa è precipitata anche la
nasa sta investendo negli stereotipi nel
combattere gli stereotipi
ora questa è una foto devono correre
questa è una foto che farà 50 anni e il
24 dicembre spesa da pollo 8 quindi la
prima foto della terra vista da fuori
presa appunto sette mesi prima dello
sbarco sulla luna e la prima donna nello
spazio in realtà fu valentina tereskova
il terzo uomo nello spazio fu valentina
yuri gagarin nel 61 shepard e nel 63
valentina tereskova la prima donna per
tre giorni nella sua casa da post hoc
che è appunto privata pilota una
navicella salirà in arrivo venti anni
dopo le donne furono escluse dai
programmi gemini apollo mercury e con se
l'italia appunto si aprirà una nuova
fase e la prima europea
quello di ieri nel 96 ora interessante
che gli ingegneri quando aprirono le
donne cominciano a chiedersi che forse
volevano essere carina anche nello
spazio anche fluttuando nello spazio
volevano essere belle erano questione di
priorità si inventarono unti con kit di
di trucco addirittura discutendo per
giorni se era meglio mettere il mascara
meglio mettere rossetto comunque non ha
mai volato e
al museo di washington crudel di gatto è
questo allora innanzitutto a 600
stronati finora solo 60 donne
il green gap è la differenza che già
comincia a 50 in una bambina tra il tuo
potenziale e la tua capacità di crederci
ai maschietti si regalano giocano a che
fare con la scienza le femminucce no i
genitori domandano google a mio figlio è
bravo bravo a scuola e brillante ma non
mia figlia
quindi bisogna le bambine hanno bisogno
di aiuto per potersi autorizzare a
sognare destra stronati presidenti
ingegneri avvocati e così via
vi faccio vedere questa è una versione
di ingiustizia che è dentro di noi non
sopportiamo supportiamo comportamenti
diversi sono gli ottimi legione no in
questo esperimento lei ci mette danno
una pietra e ottengono qualcosa da
mangiare fino allora hanno avuto
cetriolo quindi questa ci mette dice vai
adesso anche io prendo l'uva come
l'altra invece risi ribeca il cetriolo e
quello che dice quindi si arrabbia non
tollera che da un altro dei minori e
devo dire è meglio non continuare perché
tira giù tutto quindi abbiamo bisogno di
un mondo più giusto
la scienza ha bisogno di donne per il
clima change per ridurre la povertà la
fame e le donne il bisogno di chance a
preoccupare quegli spazi dove il futuro
si immagina e si costruisce finisco con
una poesia sono in ritardo
questo è il guai il voyager che lascia
il sistema solare si gira per salutare
la terra con un bimbo che viene lasciato
scuola il primo giorno e si gira a
salutare la mamma e e finisco con questa
poesia della sim brosca che sia
disattenzione
ieri mi sono comportata male nel cosmo
ha passato tutto il giorno senza fare
domande
il savoir faire cosmico benché traccia
sul nostro conto tuttavia sige qualcosa
da noi un po più di attenzione qualche
frase di pascal è una partecipazione
stupita a questo gioco
brignone grazie
[Applauso]